Oh!
(audience claps)
What is up, Drew?
Well, before we dig in,
I saw that you posted this on Instagram,
and I actually commented on it.
Oh no, uh-oh.
And I started going down a rabbit hole
the other day.
Oh!
I've definitely had that moment
Yes.
where I started a cleaning project
and suddenly got way too deep.
What happened?
I, the same, it's in a corner, and I have to get to it.
And my husbands like, when is it going to happen?
And I'm like, don't rush greatness.
(laughs)
Yeah. That's like the new, like tired, thirst trap.
Being like I'm Marie Kondo-ing, what are you doing?
I have learned on the show,
because we've had a lot of Marie Kondo,
mm hmm, mm hmm.
the home edit, all these like authorities
in this field, and they all say start small.
So you really do.
This is what happened to me the other day.
I got into my jewelry cabinet and went way too far.
I ended up crying my eyes out.
That's a lot.
Are those bracelets?
Do you wear everything?
Do you remember all what you have?
No, and I brought most of it here to leave,
so that we could wear it for the show.
Cause I'm like,
I only wear sweatpants and t-shirts at home.
Yeah.
So I kind of, but I, I bit off way more than I could chew.
I feel like I have to go back home and fold laundry truly.
But um... (audience laughs)
And also like, there is a story
I was really excited to talk about with you,
which is that, so apparently there's a new syndrome.
mm hmm.
It's not FOMO.
It's FODA, which is...
InStyle reports that FODA stands for 'Fear of Dating Again.'
Whoa.
And a lot of singles are starting
to get real sweaty palms about resuming in-person dates.
And experts want people to realize that you're not alone.
Everyone out there is a little rusty as well,
including your new date.
Michelle, thoughts?
I think you have to be as honest as possible.
You know, we have been home in quarantine
for a really long time.
And I think like, get it all out there.
There don't even waste time getting to know each other
politely over texts.
You know, you went through so much trouble just to meet
for that coffee in public right now.
It's all got to mean something.
You know, what side of science are you on?
You know, do you have health insurance?
What do you plan to do?
Did you finish your script?
You know what I mean?
Do you have to like sell your car to make that music album?
I can't, we're not talking about me.
I'm married, but the point is, yeah.
I say, get it all out there.
You know, just don't wait.
Don't wait.
Do you know what's interesting, Michelle,
is this article actually really backs that up
and has your same theory.
They talk about honesty.
And when I heard you use those examples,
some funny, some truth, some funny because it's true.
Mm hmm, mm hmm.
It made me feel really comfortable with the idea
of honesty because it doesn't have to be so heavy.
It can just be like your fun truth.
Are you out there trying to...
What, what's going on?
You know, I just closed my dating app today, actually.
Ooh, child!
I had gotten on cause I was like, you know, why not?
Yeah.
Like, let's try it.
Yes!
And then I just realized that I'm not ready.
That's okay.
It will happen when ready.
And sometimes don't even know you're ready.
Do you know what I mean?
Everyone's in a rush and for what?
Nothing will make you edit your plans like a pandemic.
Like my husband and I love each other,
but at one point we were talking to each other
like we were trying to talk to Alexa,
like not hearing a song.
Yeah.
We're like, What?
I can't hear you, what?"
Oh, look at my husband Gijs.
Those are very cute.
Oh...
He's Dutch, that's Amsterdam.
You guys get it.
Oh, I love Amsterdam.
I love him, and I love you.
Okay, your story's next.
Michelle!
Yes. I'm very excited.
A story where I could be the embedded reporter.
Uh-huh, uh-huh, uh-huh.
New scientist reports twins are at an all time high.
I'm sorry, all I do is twin twin twin.
In the eighties there were nine sets of twins born
for every thousand births.
And today there's 12 twins for every thousand births.
(gasps)
That is three more.
I'm good at math.
Experts say it's because of IVF,
but also women are having babies later.
And as women age, they're more likely to release
two eggs at once.
That's a two for one.
So yeah, I mean, it's exciting.
I also feel like with this knowledge that, you know,
Shark Tank and all these places that make baby items
should keep that into consideration, you know?
And make stuff less expensive,
because I've had to get two of everything with my twins.
You know what I've scene in, 'I Love Lucy'
where the chocolate's on the conveyor belt,
and she's like "I gotta get the chocolate?"
That's what it felt like for, mmmm, what year is it?
For two years.
Yeah.
They're two years old.
And so sometimes I take pictures of them
just so I can remember what they look like
or even see what they look like.
And they're starting preschool or?
They're starting daycare in a few days.
How does that milestone feel?
Ahh... For them, I, you know, I think they'll love it.
For me it feels why wild, duh, duh, duh, duh, oh.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Like I haven't even been in a restaurant,
I can't leave Yelp reviews,
and now I'm going to drop my kids
off to a place I've never seen with people I've never seen?
But you know what the good part is is that I'm on TV.
So if anything happens (laughs)
You gonna make it to Drew's News.
Right here.
Yeah.
We hold people accountable,
But yes, don't mess with my meatballs.
Speaking of meatballs, what, what kind of segue is that?
I'm gonna (indistinct).
I don't know, but that's a segue I can get behind.
Huffpost reports that Ikea,
the only store that tires you out so bad,
you need a tray of 25 meatballs.
Ooh. And a dollar ice cream cone. Oof.
To recover is offering a new plant ball.
It's just like, their famous Swedish meatballs,
but it's made a plants.
Guys every time we say ball
just take a sip of your coffee.
Now, honey.
I don't know if you know this about me, but I love me
a meatball party.
It's like sort of my Thanksgiving.
Really?
But like my friends-giving, yes.
Everybody brings over a meatball that they made.
Is it a meatball potluck?
It is, we call it swap meet.
And so we taste test all the meatballs.
And if you don't bring a ball, you bring rosé,
and it's just so much fun.
And then like we usually end up wall-twerking,
but that's okay, you know?
I would love to like eat meatballs
and wall-twerk with you.
That's so funny you mention that.
because we have meatballs right here.
Okay.
And we can twerk.
Yes, and we can twerk.
And we even have an animation,
so you know it's a real party!
That's right, roll it!
(upbeat clapping and music)
Oh, oh, oh, oh, get it, get it, get it, get it.
Uh-huh, uh-huh, uh-huh.
The music was very short, but I still hear it in my head.
I know, it's a new music cue for us.
I'm excited. All right.
This is very exciting.
Okay so...
Now we have a ball flight.
Yes, yes.
I have some Jamaican jerk chicken meatballs over here
that you can sample.
And then my classic Italian meatball.
Oh yeah. That's good.
Isn't that good?
It's so moist and delicious.
Now, Ikea plant balls.
Not bad, not bad.
I need some Lingonberry sauce to go with it.
Yeah. Now for the jerk chicken ball.
Oh, that's spicy.
What is that, nutmeg?
Ooh, it is nutmeg!
mm hmm.
Oh that's delicious.
It's good.
So here's my feeling
mm hmm.
about the Ikea balls.
I think the Ikea's a really pleasant texture,
it just needs a little seasoning.
Well, what I wanted to do was dip the plant ball
into your sauce.
It's better already.
Yeah. Night and day.
Need a little sauce.
Yeah, it needed sauce.
Sometimes you need a little sauce.
You need a little gravy. You need a little...
You know what I mean?
Yes. Now it's a little different.
Yeah. And I wouldn't mind a toothpick with it either.
I feel like my teeth are like impacting by the day,
and that's why more food keeps getting stuck in there.
As soon as I find out what that means,
I'm going to agree with you.
It's just, I'm just slowly dying.
(upbeat music)